Vsauce!
Kevin here.
Go to a restaurant - look at the menu - and
then eat it.
Molecular Gastronomy is an innovative way
of cooking that combines culinary arts with
science.
As food is prepared and combined -- in what's
called a "colloidal system" -- ingredients
go through physical and chemical changes.
Chefs utilizing Molecular Gastronomy use their
artistic and technical abilities to influence
the food's transformations.
These techniques turn boring, traditional
cuisine into a modern sensory experience.
By looking at food simply as states of matter
- in different types of colloidal systems
- foam, solid foam, gel, emulsion and solid
emulsion - molecular gastronomists prepare
unique dishes like this deconstructed baby
corn or this creative take on lemon chicken.
And they bring unique tools into the kitchen
such as hypodermic syringes for spherification
- which involves liquid-filled beads that
create gel equivalents of foods ranging from
caviar to ravioli, the vacuum machine is used
to suck out air from a bag in order to use
a technique called sous vide - which slowly
cooks the food in heated water to retain moisture
or another important tool that they use liquid
nitrogen.
Robyn Sue Fisher, founder of Smitten Ice Cream
in San Francisco wanted to make ice cream
as fresh as possible that didn't require a
bunch of chemicals to preserve -- and her
solution was liquid nitrogen.
It's Nitrogen at an extremely low temperature
in a liquid state, first liquefied at the
Jagiellonian University in 1883 by Polish
Physicists Zygmunt Wroblewski (ro-bleh-ski)
and Karol Olszewski.
By using Liquid Nitrogen, Fisher found that
she could rapidly freeze ice cream, allowing
her to make each serving fresh right when
a customer orders.
Chef Homaro Cantu at Moto Restaurant in Chicago
makes edible menus.
This "bread and butter" menu was one of their
first.
Cantu's masticable menus include one printed
on a salad roll - which after reading the
menu, the customer just rolls it up and eats
it.
For the printing they use a modified inkjet
printer with cartridges filled with food-based
ink like juiced carrots, tomatoes and purple
potatoes.
One of Moto's most innovative courses is a
play on fried chicken in which noodles and
biscuits are made with dehydrated freeze--dried
chicken ground into a powder.
If you want to experiment with Molecular Gastronomy
yourself - the youtube channel Molecule-r
Flavors has tutorials anyone can follow with
the right ingredients -- like this frozen
chocolate wind that uses soy lecithin, which
is a natural emulsifier that changes watery
solutions into an air-like substance.
Or these surprise bubbles that uses calcium
lactate and sodium alginate, derived from
brown algae, to create spheres.
You can also check out their website that
offers kits with everything you need to try
Molecular Gastronomy techniques at home.
Enthusio chefs is another great channel featuring
videos like this reverse spherified poached
egg that uses xantham gum, a mixture of two
calcium salts called gluco, and egg white
powder to recreate just the whites of a poached
egg.
They also make powdered ice cream inside candy
strawberries and Milk Milk Milk, where they
use milk to make cheese and foam and create
this...
While to some Molecular Gastronomy could be
considered a novelty it does combine science,
technology, creativity and sustenance in exciting
ways.
And really I just kinda want to try strawberry
spaghetti - what about cheeseburger spaghetti...?
Pizza spaghetti?!
And as always thanks for watching.